China's response to the corona virus
outbreak under fire as some states look
to hold the communist country rightfully
accountable Mississippi now the latest
to sue the Chinese government blaming
what they call quote a cover-up
for the suffering of more than 5000
residents infected with the virus in the
state not to mention the businesses
impacted Mississippi's Attorney General
Lynn Fitch joins us now Lynn good
morning thank you for being here tell us
about the suit that you were bringing on
behalf of behalf of Mississippi against
the Communist Chinese good morning it's
a pleasure to be with you all this
morning well I'll take my role as the
Attorney General is to protect all
Mississippians their health the security
and their prosperity so by bringing this
suit it allows Mississippians to seek
justice and whole China accountable
because if you look at what they've done
this has been a very malicious it's been
a very dangerous cover-up the corona
virus has killed
Crona virus has caused serious medical
damage and harm across our country our
state mr. story our businesses and it's
functionally altered the way Americans
will live so we have to rebuild and so
we see the damages that caught the
issues that they have caused
Mississippians so I'm bringing the suit
on behalf of Mississippians Attorney
General I would never miss with never
count-out or mess with Mississippi but
what are the prospects of this lawsuit
against one of the largest countries on
the planet who's gonna want to just swat
it aside doesn't even take
responsibility on the international
stage well that's true you mean it's
certainly a tough lawsuit however it's
the right thing to do we must hold them
accountable they've gone in and they
have silenced doctors and journalists
whistleblowers they have caused us not
to be prepared and this has damaged us
on so many levels loss of life economic
damages and so it's a tough one
but we're going to win because we're
going to hold them accountable and we
must do that in order to make them not
to go down this path here they cannot
continue to deceive and take advantage
of America amen well said and good luck
with the suit I have to ask you as the
chief lawmaker there in Mississippi you
know bill Barr has called into question
some of the stay at home orders
vielen saying they they get close to
house arrest how far should government
goes how have you viewed the powers in
the state of Mississippi as far as
allowing residents to get back to work
well we're always ready to get back to
work
but we're going to do it very carefully
very cautiously following the executive
orders of our governor it's important
that we phase in because we must again
protect all Mississippians their health
but at the same time do the right thing
go the right avenues and pathways to get
us back into you know economic
prosperity that's right now the feeling
in Mississippi the Bill of Rights is not
above your paygrade like governor Murphy
said in new jersey so good stuff the
Attorney General thank you so much for
joining us is when a good luck with that
suit against the Communist Chinese we
appreciate it
all right thank you for having me you
got it